all right I enjoyed this recent report
from CNN they went to investigate the
shoplifting epidemic in San Francisco
and let's watch what happened during
this investigation
Richard Greenberg walked into a San
Francisco Walgreens when he saw in the
frozen food section this change heavy
chains that went from padlock to padlock
on both sides of the doors and this was
bizarre something I'd never seen before
this is just
or icing on the cake
telling us that rampant crime is is has
become a regular part of life so typical
that in the 30 minutes we were at this
Walgreens
we watched three people including this
man steal did that guy pay
did that guy pay
he didn't pay
Walgreens says this Richmond
neighborhood store with aisles of
products like mustard locked behind
Plexiglas has the highest theft rate of
all their nearly 9 000 U.S stores hit
more than a dozen times a day when
thieves turned to cleaning out ice cream
and frozen burritos workers grew so
frustrated they resorted to the chains
they were ordered down by corporate
because of the negative messaging
but Walgreens isn't the only retailer
impacted in San Francisco
have to ask an employee for help at this
store frozen food is controlled with a
cable lock fake eyelashes locked behind
Plexiglas along with lotion and nail
polish
at another grocery store 14 bags of
coffee under lock and key what is this
um I don't know I don't understand why
coffee I don't know here she is
it's become kind of like a police state
in San Francisco I don't know how to
describe it
police state sure it's a police state
where people casually stroll into a
convenience store and leave with a
handful of merchandise without any fear
of any sort of prosecution that's a
police state
no that's that's the exact opposite of
police what you are seeing is the exact
opposite of a police state
companies don't companies don't lock up
their bags of coffee behind padlocks in
a police state
that happens in a state with no police
so it is again very much the opposite
problem that you're experiencing in San
Francisco
but as always you know it's very
revealing to look at the kinds of
merchandise
that places like Walgreens and other
stores have to put behind lock and key
it's uh expensive bags of coffee ice
cream frozen burritos fake eyelashes
nail polish lotion pancake syrup
now
what's the significance of that well
these are not the items that you grab if
you are starving and malnourished
which means that poverty is not driving
this problem
somebody who's poor and desperate and
needs to steal to survive is it going to
steal Pete's coffee or carton of cookie
dough ice cream
I've been broke
okay I was broke for several years I
didn't steal Gourmet Coffee bags or
cartons of ice cream I just didn't buy
them that's what you do when you're
broke you just don't buy that stuff I
went through years of my life where I
never went to the grocery store and
bought dessert or expensive coffee
couldn't afford it
I was surviving I was I was fine I
wasn't gonna die but uh but I just
couldn't afford that kind of stuff so I
didn't buy it
and it was okay
so what you're seeing here is not
poverty being poor alone doesn't cause
you to do that
just does
what causes this is when you are totally
indifferent
so what we're seeing in San Francisco
along with a lot of other things is
total indifference it is a form of
Despair but
but it's not despair brought on by
Financial desperation it's the despair
of simply not caring about anything
having no moral compass just doing
whatever you want because you want to
that's the despair gripping hold of San
Francisco in many places in America and
it's encouraged and facilitated by the
government which is not enforcing the
law
you know a company is looking out for
you when they actually upgrade your
service and don't charge you for it this
is great news for new and current Pure
Talk customers pure talk just added data
to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increases
whatsoever if you've considered pure
talk before but haven't made the switch
yet take a look again for just twenty
dollars a month you'll get unlimited
talk text and now 50 more 5G data plus
their new mobile hotspot this is why I
love Pure Talk they're veteran owned and
only hire the best customer service team
located right here in the great USA most
families are saving almost a thousand
dollars a year while enjoying the most
Dependable 5G Network in America
remember you vote with how you spend
your money so stop supporting wireless
companies that don't support you when
you go to puretalk.com Walsh you'll save
an additional 50 off the first month
because they actually value you that's
puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans by Americans if
you love venturing into the Great
Outdoors and you know that staying
connected is essential for safety and
peace of mind that's where satellite
phone store comes in their devices help
you stay in touch with friends family
and Emergency Services even when you're
far from cellular coverage satellite
phone stores baby stick and satellite
Communicator use satellite networks for
phone calls text messages GPS navigation
and an SOS feature for emergency
situations if you're not sure which
device is right for you think about
where you'll be using the device and
what features are most important to you
and you can figure it out from there if
you need a lightweight compact option
for backpacking a bivvy stick might be
the better choice however if you want a
more robust device with additional
features like weather forecasts and
two-way messaging a satellite
Communicator could be the better option
for you something that brings me peace
of mind is knowing that even in a global
disaster satellite phones will keep me
and my beloved ones always connected for
a limited time satellite phone store has
a special promotional offer when you go
to a sat123.com Welsh you'll get a free
baby stick or a free in marsat satellite
phone included with an applicable annual
agreement head over to
sat123.com Walsh that's sat123.com Walsh
and get your device today
you know what someone who's stealing ice
cream from Walgreens you know what they
need
what they need most of all
they need a consequence okay they need
consequences
in fact everybody needs consequences
this is a basic human need
when you live a life free of consequence
it it's it breeds despair
because without consequence you don't
have Direction you don't have meaning
and you end up with San Francisco A
Wasteland where people are just
wandering around like zombies and it's
disgusting and gross and depressing and
ugly
it's what you end up with and that's the
other thing too
ugliness okay
here's what we have to understand
ugliness
will always be a part of life
uh in this Fallen world that we live in
there will always be ugliness
and we as a society have to choose what
kind of ugliness we want each Society
chooses its form of ugliness it's kind
of like in Ghostbusters when they had to
choose the form of their Destructor and
it shows the marshmallow man well each
Society must choose its ugliness so
people don't like
um especially these days we don't like
prisons we don't like police arresting
people
that's ugly it's an ugly thing it is
prisons are ugly places they're not they
are they're not beautiful it's not
beautiful it's not beautiful to be in a
prison it's an ugly place it looks ugly
ugly things are happening the whole
thing is ugly the fact that people need
to go to prison is ugly it's all it's
all very ugly
um
arresting someone it's it's a very ugly
thing and it can get even uglier
a police try to arrest them if they're
just arresting someone for stealing ice
cream and if the person resists then the
police have to use Force because if they
don't use force and there's no point of
even having the cops in the first but I
mean if someone can resist arrest and
the cops have to go well okay if you
don't want to be arrested never mind
then that's just the same thing as not
having cops in the first place so if
you're going to have the law the need to
have law enforcement and if you're gonna
have law enforcement it means it means
it has to it it requires a it requires
Force violence
and so they're arresting someone for
something Petty and the person resists
and so now they have to use force and
that person uses divorce also
and sometimes uh that person ends up
dead we've seen that many times George
Floyd
starts with uh with the twenty dollars
counterfeit bill
and what we often hear from the left is
is it is it worth
police are going to kill someone over a
20 Bill gonna kill someone over
shoplifting is it worth that
well the answer is yes I mean it is now
the way you're phrasing that is is not
totally honest it's not like the cops
just showed up and shot someone dead
because they were using a counterfeit
money or because they stole something
so they weren't tilled for that
but they were killed in the process of
enforcing the laws against that
and it's a very ugly thing it is
but the point is that if you don't want
that ugliness if you say it's too ugly I
don't want it it's enforcing a law it's
a very ugly thing I don't want it I
don't we don't want it in society until
it makes my tummy hurt to look at it
don't want it makes me feel
uncomfortable
having all these people in in jails we
hear the left complain about they give
us the stats and all the people in jail
uh it makes me feel like all those
people in jail that's not right I feel
bad about that that's mean
well okay
so we're not gonna have that ugliness
anymore the ugliness of enforcing the
law and punishing people and consequence
and that sort of thing
but you don't escape ugliness then what
happens is that the ugliness is
elsewhere and in this case it's
everywhere
so if you don't want to contain the
ugliness you're going to end up with it
everywhere everything becomes ugly in
San Francisco they do not have the
ugliness of enforcing laws arresting
people carting them off to jail they
don't have that
and so in exchange everything is ugly
in exchange they have uh you know bags
of coffee behind padlocks in the in the
at the convenience store
okay in exchange if you want to go buy a
grocery item you have to you have to be
escorted to the aisle by an employee who
takes out a big uh a big key ring and
unlocks it and hands it to you
that's what you get in exchange for not
having the ugliness of law enforcement
um
I prefer the other option
you know where where at least then the
ugly things are contained
and if you are going to have to face
that kind of ugly thing is because you
chose to
you know you chose to steal and now
you've put yourself in a very ugly
situation
which means you're in the cops are going
to come you're going to go to jail it's
gonna not gonna be good for you really
ugly situation but you chose it
you chose it
as opposed to now if you don't have law
enforcement you don't have consequence
then everyone has to deal with the
ugliness whether they chose it or not if
you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed